what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 preview video in the next episode
we're going to see one of the greatest
battles in the history of Game of
Thrones which I've called the field of
fire 2.0 since the very beginning Jaime
Lannister just took care of business at
Highgarden
but his victory march is about to be
short-lived once the NARAS Targaryen in
her Dothraki savages catch them by
surprise in the open field
but the Lannisters have a brand new
alliance with the greatest military
commander left in his series Lord
randyll Tarly but even with his
expertise it will not be enough to stop
the wrath of Daenerys Targaryen Jaime
Lannister and his men just sacked the
[ __ ] out of Highgarden and are now
making their way back with plenty of the
Tyrells valuable resources but before
that money is spent or all of that food
is divided up the Lannister army will be
delivered a devastating blow by one of
Robert Baratheon's biggest fears which
was meeting the Dothraki out in the open
field the spoils of war is reported to
be on par with the Battle of the
bastards they hired hundreds and
hundreds of extras and over a hundred
horses to be used for this epic battle
against the Lannisters and the Targaryen
in more bodies were burned in this
upcoming episode than every other
episode combined we can expect to see
over 75 people get burned alive by
Daenerys dragons during this ambush this
battle should take up about half of the
episode and with everything that's going
to happen I don't think anyone is going
to be disappointed by it but the
Lannisters aren't about to go down
without a fight
and the tarly's aren't about to go down
without a fight either
especially when you have one of the
greatest battle commanders of all time
at the helm but before this episode ends
nearly every Lannister and Tarly soldier
will be dead except for Jaime and Bronn
of course remember Kai Burns brand new
weapon that he showed to Cersei we will
see the Dragons flame crossbow put into
action during this battle not only will
we see this gigantic crossbow get used
but it will enter the dragon which will
give Jaime Lannister the opportunity to
make one mad dash at it to put it out of
its misery in the season 7 trailer we
can see Jaime Lannister charging on his
horse like a bat out of hell across the
burning battlefield and I believe he is
charging at Daenerys and her dragon
Jaime will see that he has
chance to kill it and he will do
everything in his power to put it down
for good
but at the last moment I think the
dragon will turn its head right at Jamie
and breathe its fire right at him and
nearly kill him but Jamie will be saved
just in time by brawn but let me explain
how this is going to happen there is
another scene from the season 7 trailer
that shows someone diving into some
water and fire shoots out above I
believe that is Jaime Lannister getting
tackled or pushed into some water by
Bronn right before the dragon completely
ignites his one-handed ass in flames
when the trailer came out everyone said
this is Theon jumping into some water
which wasn't a bad guess but I made a
video and I provided a good bit of solid
evidence that I thought that proved this
was going to be Jaime and Bronn during
the field of fire but let's take a
closer look at this clip one last time
before episode 4 airs right before this
person goes into the water if you look
out above it you can see what I think is
sunlight shining through the water some
people told me it was moonlight shining
through but I think that sunlight
we already saw Theon jump into the water
at night and they never showed him
jumping into the water from this angle
as we can see from the preview footage
this battle against the Lannisters and
as a threat key will take place during
the daytime which is why I think that
sunlight coming through and I think
that's dragon fire shooting across the
water that just misses Jaime and Bronn
if you slow it down and look closely you
can see that that fire shoots across the
water in a straight line the same way
dragons fire shoots out in a straight
line just like we've seen him do before
this is going to be a pretty badass
scene when I saw Jaime charging across
the burning battlefield I got so excited
to finally see Jaime take charge and put
its fighting skills to good use other
than fighting Ned and Brienne Jaime
looks like an absolute madman charging
at Daenerys and her dragon and this
takes a lot of balls when you know once
that dragon sets its eyes on you it's a
wrap and Jaime would get cooked alive
inside of that armor if it wasn't for
Bronn who's going to be here to save him
just in time I've been looking forward
to the spoils of war ever since I first
caught wind of how much the budget they
were going to be spending on this
episode and more specifically this
battle sequence this is going to be an
absolute bloodbath you have to keep in
mind how pissed Daenerys Targaryen is
right now she just lost
all of her major alliances that she
arrived in Westeros with and we are only
halfway through the season Daenerys was
expecting to conquer Westeros and get
everyone to kneel fairly quickly but
things have not went as planned she
showed up with this massive army and
massive fleet that has started to
dwindle away pretty damn fast
she lost her Greyjoy fleet almost as
soon as she arrived the sand snakes were
just completely removed from the game
and they were going to provide the
Dornan soldiers to help lay siege to
King's Landing
then the Tyrells are now out of the
equation as well and they were supposed
to lay siege to King's Landing with the
Dornish also so that plan has now went
to [ __ ] and she lost her Greyjoy
alliance as well not only is Yara locked
up in King's Landing right now but Fiona
isn't much help at all in his own and
with no more ships to provide he has
nothing at all that he could bring to
the table for the next strategy Daenerys
has lost three major alliances and the
only thing she has to show for it is
Casterly Rock and Casterly Rock only had
a small amount of Lannister men there so
she didn't even hurt the Lannisters that
much by taking it at this moment and on
the other hand
Cersei now has two new alliances that
are very formidable in battles we saw
what your on Greyjoy is capable of in
randyll Tarly 's career speaks for
itself as of right now the Lannisters
are winning and they have an anti dragon
weapon just waiting to be used
Cersei Lannister is also going to end up
with the iron bank supplying her with
the funds to strengthen her forces
Benares Targaryen is actually getting
her ass kicked right now so when she
ambushes the Lannisters in the open
field in the next episode this is a
must-win for Daenerys she has got to win
this battle she cannot afford to lose
all of her Dothraki men either but even
with all that being said
Daenerys still has the greatest threat
Westeros has ever known to worry about
she still has to help defeat the night
team everyone in Westeros needs to wake
up and realize they can't afford to lose
all their best soldiers fighting each
other or else when the night King comes
they will have no one strong enough left
to beat them back and beat them into
submission
I think things are getting pretty damn
interesting now Daenerys is going to
need to find a way to take care of the
land
star swiftly without losing much else in
the process the spoils of war is a big
episode smacked right dab in the middle
of the season which goes to show just
how epic this season could end up being
typically a battle of this size would be
at the end of a season since this is an
episode four that means whatever they
have in store for us in Episode six and
seven has to be something amazing with
Casterly Rock and Highgarden now being
taken the pace of the show is going to
pick up even more from here on out
the struggle for who has control of the
Seven Kingdoms is underway in Daenerys
is feeling the power shift it seemed as
if Daenerys was going to be an
unstoppable force but Cersei has shown
us once again that she is more resilient
than given credit in the only way
Daenerys will ever get full control of
the Seven Kingdoms is if she can deliver
a knockout blow to the crown that Cersei
continues to wear and it is about the
shift gears in the next episode Jaime
Lannister is also proving to be very
useful even with only one good hand and
when he sees the dragon in a vulnerable
position he's going to have the taste of
victory right on the tips of his golden
fingers once again but coming face to
face with the Dragons fire is going to
Humble his ass real quick but it's going
to be interesting to see how the
Lannisters make their adjustments after
this this may give Jaime the insight to
what he can do next time to take a
dragon down for good and really turn the
tide against an Aerys Targaryen I can't
wait to see how the rest of this season
plays out things are really starting to
heat up now literally and figuratively
but comment down below with your
questions and thoughts let me know what
you thought about episode 3 and let me
know what you think is going to happen
in episode 4 do you think that's Jaime
Lannister avoiding the dragon fire in
the clip above or do you still think
that's Theon or somebody else let me
know down below I'm going to work on my
breakdown for episode 3 right now and
I'm going to have that video up within
the next 15 hours of you listening to
this one I just want to say thanks for
stopping by the channel and checking out
this video make sure you come back all
week long because I'm going to be
releasing videos every single day I want
to thank all of my patreon supporters
also for always showing love it really
means a lot to me so have a good night
and I'll see you for the episode 3
breakdown bye
[Music]
you